alan dershowitz is a well-known attorney
and legal scholar historically a civil
libertarian considered a man of the left
for many years by any reasonable
assessment he's a scholar of
constitutional law a scholar of criminal
law he's been involved in many
high-profile cases he teaches at Harvard
and something happened to Dershowitz
over the last few years really around
Donald Trump where he has become an
unhinged defender of Donald Trump and
someone who has touted some very strange
legal theories and he jumped into the
Russia probe witch-hunt nonsense he's
become a completely untrustworthy guy on
all counts and he is now claiming that
essentially even if all allegations
against Trump are proven Trump still
would not be impeachable check this out
he's been making the rounds he did it on
ABC's this week with George
Stephanopoulos yesterday where he said
if everything Trump is accused of is
proven Donald Trump still cannot be
impeached so is it your position that
President Trump should not be impeached
even if all the evidence and arguments
laid out by the house are accepted as
fact that's right when you have somebody
who for example is indicted for a crime
let's assume you have a lot of evidence
but the grand jury simply indict for
something that's not a crime and that's
what happened here you have a lot of
evidence disputed evidence could go both
ways but the vote was to impeach on
abuse of power which is not within the
constitutional criteria for impeachment
and obstruction of Congress those are
both the kinds of things that led
Hamilton and Madison talk about
nightmare to regard that as the greatest
nightmare number one giving Congress too
much power to allow the President to
serve at the will of Congress and number
two as Hamilton put it the greatest
danger is turning impeachment into a
question of who has the most votes in
which house and rather than having a
consensus and a broad broad view of
impeachable car brief so can't impeach
because he's not been impeached for
something that is a crime now
hilariously check out what Alan
Dershowitz was saying back when it was
Bill Clinton's impeachment this is video
from the infamous Larry King Live back
in nine
a program I grew up with where
Dershowitz says impeachment is serious
you don't have to impeach over a crime
if someone has corrupted the office of
the presidency what a different point of
view back then it certainly doesn't have
to be a crime if you have somebody who
completely corrupts the office of
president and who abuses trust and who
poses great danger to our Liberty you
don't need a technical crime but
remember that because the executive
power is vested in one person the
president unlike the judicial power
which is vested in justices of the
Supreme Court and inferior judges well
the legislative power and 100 senators
and 402 impeach a president is like a
non-violent revolution it is the most
dramatic act of undoing democracy that
is possible and that's why the framers
use the term treason bribery high crimes
and misdemeanors to suggest the English
analogy to great offenses of state we
look at their acts of state we look at
how they conduct the foreign policy we
look at whether they try to subvert the
Constitution the way iran-contra did it
certainly doesn't have to be a crime
Donald Trump has now hired Alan
Dershowitz he has also hired Kenneth
Starr the special prosecutor who brought
an investigated impeachment against Bill
Clinton consider how insane this is
given that back during the Bill Clinton
impeachment days Alan Dershowitz was on
the opposite side of Ken Starr and said
Ken Starr is a risk to American liberty
and they are now working together to
defend Donald Trump against impeachment
this is not a case of politics makes
strange bedfellows this is more than
that the one consistent thing I will say
about Dershowitz is that as a civil
libertarian he has held some version of
the position that Special Investigations
like the one against Clinton and the one
by robert muller against trump are
starting to get to the edges of the
power of investigators to search around
for crimes he's been relatively
consistent in that overarching principle
but on these other issues the big
picture is Dershowitz has gone from
being a liberal Harvard professor
sir to one of the most prominent
defenders a priori of everything that
Donald Trump does or might do there's a
really interesting article that I've
previously recommended it's from 28 2018
it was written in Politico magazine and
it's called what happened to Alan
Dershowitz and it talks about all of the
judges and legal scholars who know
Dershowitz personally they can't figure
out what happened to the guy it doesn't
seem that it would be for money he's
worth about 25 million bucks and it's
not really clear how profitable the
Trump apologia is anyway it might be the
idea of being close to power I don't
know of another president that
Dershowitz has been this close to and
has had such a prominent relationship
maybe he likes the idea of that he's on
an 81 year old guy at this point it's
all very strange it's a very sad way to
close out a long legal career and we can
expect more of the same from Alan
Dershowitz as the Senate impeachment
trial gets going the plan as of now I
will say is to stream as much of it as
we can I still have not found anything
definitive about whether Mitch McConnell
is going to force the coverage to be
just like one fixed camera really far
away in the Senate or whether they will
actually allow c-span to do a
multi-camera production of the trial the
way that they do of Senate proceedings
in in general but my goal is tomorrow
1:00 p.m. Eastern Time Tuesday is the
first day of the trial my goal is to be
streaming and we will see if we could
make that happen